foreign
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
the European commission's uh Press Room
president from The Lion and Dr fatibiral
the executive director of the
International Energy agency will talk to
you about energy and with no further Ado
I give the floor to the president
thank you very much good afternoon and
I'm very happy to welcome here fatimul
indeed we had a very good discussion on
an energy outlook on for Europe and how
to deal with the unprecedented
disruptions that are have been caused by
Russia's atrocious War
Russia indeed has cut its pipeline
supplies by 80 if you compare September
this year
to September last year 80 and we all
know that these pipeline gas Cuts have
added unprecedented pressure on the
global energy markets with severe
knock-on effects on Europe's Energy
System
but I want to emphasize that despite
these enormous Cuts we have been able to
manage we have been able to withstand
the black male we've acted and we've
acted successfully
seven months ago in may we have
presented our response
to this Russian blackmail by putting on
the table repower EU I'll plan to reduce
the demand for Russian girls by
two-thirds before the end of this year
and we have underpinned this proposal
with a investment plan of up to 300
billion euros
and in just a few months we have turned
the repower EU plan into many different
legislative proposals and actions on the
ground
and I think it's worth to look at that
basically we have taken in the last 10
months 10 different actions the first
one is we have
um enormously Diversified away from
Russian fossil fuels away from Russian
gas supplies
towards other reliable trustworthy
suppliers
second we are saving energy we have
introduced as you all know the target to
reduce gas Demand by 15 percent and if
we look at the data from Early Autumn we
are very well on track it's good that we
are saving energy and we have keep on
saving energy
the third point is we are boosting the
rollout of Renewables if you look at the
year 2022
we will have added almost 50 gigawatt of
new capacity capacity that is almost
doubling the capacity additional
capacity of renewable energy mostly from
wind and solar
and this is for us very important
because this is not only good for the
planet but we know that Renewables are
homegrown they create good jobs here and
they create Independence and security of
supply
the fourth point is that in this context
of Renewables we have proposed to speed
up drastically the permitting process
for Renewables we know that many
projects are basically ready to go if
the permitting was there so this has to
be faster therefore we have put a
proposal on speeding up the permitting
process on the table
the fifth point is
that we have put in place a minimum gas
storage obligation
our storages are now filled by more than
90 so we have overshooted the target
that's very good
and we're well above the previous
five-year average
the sixth point is on solidarity
we have proposed default arrangements
for the supply of gas between member
states
where solidarity Agreements are not in
place yet to make sure in an energy
emergency we can ensure that the gas is
going and flowing where to it is needed
most
the seventh point is we have set up a
platform for the joint purchasing of gas
to increase our negotiation leverage and
get better prices I think it's
inacceptable that different member
states are outbidding each other on the
global market and that's driving up the
prices
therefore it is important that we join
forces for the negotiation on the global
level
the eighth point is we have improved our
infrastructure
we have four new interconnectors that
are that became operational this year
it's the Baltic pipe it's the
interconnector Poland Lithuania
the interconnector between Bulgaria and
Greece and the gas interconnector
between Poland and Slovakia
the ninth point I want to highlight is
the fact that we have
put out a legal framework that enables
member states to skim off the windfall
profits the super profits of energy
producing companies to take this money
and to support by that in a targeted
manner the vulnerable households and the
vulnerable businesses
and finally the tenth point is we
propose the market correction mechanism
known also as the price cap to limit
spikes in gas prices at ttf level
many of these measures have been adopted
some in record speed and there are many
examples that show that changes
beginning for example the massive and
Rapid uptake of heat pumps in Poland
the result of all these actions is that
we are safe for this winter Russia's
blackmail has failed
however some of our proposals are still
under discussion
and they are essential for our energy
preparedness therefore I call on the
council to adopt them swiftly because
preparing for the next winter winter 23
24 starts now
and this is now that we're turning our
focus on the winter 2324
I'm very pleased
that we've worked on that so intensively
together one month ago your message was
very clear and you underpinned your
message with figures and numbers
you said very clearly the coming winter
will be even more challenging
and Europe needs to step up its efforts
in several fields
you outline the risks it might be
possible that Russia cuts the rest of
the pipeline gas supply
China could live the covet restriction
and thus go back to energy Demand on the
global market on pre-covet level
and of course this year we benefit from
an extraordinary warm winter this also
could be different next year
I know from your data
that
despite the action that we have taken we
might still face a gap of up to 30
billion cubic meter of gas next year
the actions that we have set in motion
will help cover part of this but more is
needed
and here I want to look at a few
priorities we need to focus on the first
one is of course the LNG Supply I'm
confident that we will secure similar
volumes of LNG next year as we had this
year this year we had up to 130 billion
cubic meter of LNG and for this of
course we have to further intensify our
Outreach to our International partners
my second point is it is time now that
we make joint purchasing a reality
we have the energy platform in place
we have to Opera operationalize it now
in the joint purchasing mechanism every
day of delay comes with a price tag
we have discussions with member states
partner countries and their companies
that are ongoing
this evening tonight I will discuss this
matter with the Norwegian prime minister
for example we can launch the first
tender for demand aggregation by the end
of March but for that we need to have an
agreement on the emergency regulation we
proposed on the 18th of October and we
need it now
and my final point is
that the greatest potential
for energy in the European Union is on
our is in our own hands we must scale up
and accelerate the deployment of
Renewables we must go big and we must be
fast
with the right policies in place we can
even double the capacity of renewable
energy that we add to the market next
year
and the case has never been better
in 22 we had record editions of wind and
solar capacity to the European Union in
the European Union
and we expect renewable and capacity to
rise even further in the coming year
replacing around 12 billion cubic meter
of gas
and you are showing us with your
additional measures that we can add an
additional 7.5 billion cubic meters so
if you look at the overall scope
efficiency savings joint purchasing
Renewables
this might be the mixture we need to
make up for the missing gas next year
we've taken the action that is necessary
our proposals are now on the table
my last comment is on the bigger picture
because if we look at the bigger picture
we also see that we need an increase in
public investment in the energy
transition
mostly to ensure the competitiveness of
our European industry in the energy
transition we need additional public
investment on a national level and on a
European level
you know that in the short term we will
propose to boost repower EU re-power EU
is our vehicle the framework for
investment in cleantech
we propose to we will propose to boost
it and this is one part of our response
to the U.S inflation reduction Act
but we also know that in the midterm we
have to step up and there we will work
on setting up a sovereignty fund
to make sure that Europe continues to be
the global leader in cleantech where we
have to help our industry is now in this
high energy price environment
to make the transition to bridge the
transition to Green Clean energy that is
Affordable and secure and therefore this
funding is necessary
our work
has been
good this year we see the progress we
have come quite a long way but we know
that we are not done with our work till
families and business in the European
Union have access to energy that is
Affordable that is secure and that is
key thank you so much thank you very
much president Dr viral
thank you very much Madam president
it's a great honor for me and for my
agency to share this stage with you
today thank you very much madam
uh dear colleagues we are in the middle
of the first truly Global energy crisis
Harvard has never ever witnessed an
energy crisis of this depth and of this
complexity
all the countries around the world are
affected with this energy crisis
but of course Ukraine is the main victim
as I mentioned to uh Madam president a
few minutes ago this afternoon I am
going to meet Ukraine energy minister
galushenko
to sign a joint work program for the
next two years
first to support Ukrainian Energy System
for the next months to come
and second assist Ukraine to build a
modern Energy System after the war
but of course Europe is heavily affected
from the energy crisis as Russia was a
key supply of energy for Europe since
decades
and I I want to comment the focus that
the Madame President and her
Commissioners say brought to this issue
now in
agency has responded to the this crisis
uh very quickly in our Nimble way
24th of February was the invasion
first of March
only one week later we came up with a 10
point plan for Europe what European
countries can do in order to reduce the
Reliance on a Russian gas and what
measures need to be taken ranging from
efficiency
to Renewables penetration acceleration
of those and to the topics which are Hot
Topics in Europe such as a postponing or
facing out of nuclear power in some
countries
and they were very much aligned with the
Republic EU came from the commission and
we are very happy that the many
governments in Europe have taken up our
suggestions
now is a Madame President mentioned a
Europe has done a lot
to increase the resilience of the
European Energy System
in the last uh several months and today
we are this winter it looks like we are
off the hook
we may go through this winter with some
economic and social bruises but normally
we should go through this winter as a
result of all the measures taken in
Europe because our gas torches are very
high
but the message that I am bringing up to
you today is that the crisis is not over
and next year may well be
2023 may may be much more difficult than
this year for three reasons
first in the year 2021
Russian gas exposed to Europe was about
140 BCM
this year it went down to 60 BCM is a
2022 and it is very likely that next
year we may not have any Russian gas in
our system
so there was a decline Auntie as we all
know Russia is using the gas as a weapon
when it comes a certain political issue
so next year the first reason why we are
thinking next year may be more difficult
first Russian gas which is declining all
that substantially may not be with us at
all second LNG
as Madame President mentioned this year
we import a lot of LNG from U.S and
other sources but next year might be
even more difficult
the reason is
the amount of new LNG capacity LNG
Supply LNG coming from the exporting
countries is at Record Law only 20 BCM
we have recently never ever seen such a
small amount of additional capacity
coming
in Europe we have now we are building
many countries LNG import capacity it's
about 40 BCM coming next year but the
new LNG coming to Market is very very
limited and on top of that
China a top LNG importer of the world as
a result of a possible comeback to
economy China may already eat up a big
portion of that so LNG markets will be
taught this is the second reason
third reason why we are worried about
the next year is that the this year we
have experience uh unusually mild
temperatures
and when you look at it today and the
next days the temperature in in Europe
we may well see that the next weeks will
be a red difficult in terms of the
temperature and also uh nobody can
guarantee that next year's temperature
will be as mild as this year so putting
these three things together name it
there may not be a Russian gas
deliveries at all LNG markets will be
exceptionally tight and third we may not
be able to benefit from the mud
temperature means that we may have a
problem
so therefore we made this report that I
have the honor to launch today with the
Madame President
uh we think that next year
Europe Supply demand Gap 2023 May reach
the 30 BCM Civic number 30 BCM the gap
and if those efforts you mentioned uh
Madam president you have done with your
uh quality
this Gap would have been a 60 BCM as a
result of this efforts we have brought
down to 30 BCM this is serious Challenge
and therefore we thought what can Europe
do
between now and in next winter in order
to close this Gap what kind of measures
and which are in line with the Europe's
climate course
so you can do many things but we have
chosen the measures which are a
practical can be done in one year
very short time for energy sector of one
year and at the same time in line with
Europe Europe's climate course we have
chosen five topics and I will finish
with that the first one is faster
Improvement in Energy Efficiency
especially renovation of uh buildings
focusing on the uh and the social
housing first and providing incentive
for renovation of the buildings or
another example we have
many countries in Europe don't have in
their street lighting LED lighting move
to LED lighting incentivize them and
save energy there so first one is Energy
Efficiency we have a lot of suggestions
and examples but I've chosen these two
second faster deployment of renewals
as badam president said this year we
have seen a major record a deployment of
Renewables the reason is in the past the
main driver for Renewables in Europe was
climate change and now energy security
is the main driver of Renewables we have
seen major Improvement there and still
there is a long project Pipeline and
they are waiting for licensing and
permitting
and it is a in our view a impressive
that the countries are shortening this
license and permitting time and as it is
done in some countries that the
governments show uh the suitable uh
areas for larger uh projects and the
authoritative process it takes ages in
some countries should be done in a one
one go shops uh uh One Stop
shops in many countries
the third one is the
heat pumps one third of the European gas
is consumed in for heating in the
buildings
and going from the gas heating to
electricity heating we have already
available
proven technology heat pumps and there
is a need for further incentivizing the
heat pumps changing the electricity
tariffs to provide a additional incident
for heat pumps this could also save
again a gas
and fought
the
changing the behavior of the consumers
well-design communication campaigns
would be helpful here again according to
our analysis in Europe today the average
temperature in the buildings are about
22 degrees Celsius
bringing it down one degree Celsius
would save us about 10 BCM so
significant amount
and the fifth and the last uh uh
measure that we are suggesting is in
some of the countries that are exporting
gas to Europe
especially the countries in like Algeria
Egypt a lot of yes
is
flaring just uh through this flaring if
they are captured which is very easy and
cheap and if there's an incentive there
that gas can be just sent to Europe in
the context of uh we see them you
capture we pay for it it can provide the
additional gas to Europe
these measures are already documented in
our report you will see easily done
practical and real-world impact measures
and they would cost they wouldn't pay
for free they would cost
hundred billion euros in one year
so we have to pay 100 billion euros to
in order to implement them but
that hundred billion euros will be paid
back in two years in terms of saving
natural gas bills
so this is a in two years they pay back
this hundred billion dollar of
Investments and they will bring multiple
uh benefits
to weaken the pressure on the hustles
and the uh and the businesses this is
the perhaps a very important one second
they are where to extremely clean energy
transition third they will Comfort the
international markets and thought they
will provide the firm answer to Russia
weaponizing energy
so uh I would like to uh stop uh here
and there are some proposals We are
following it is
a president uh mentioned we very much
hope that those proposals uh Madam
president see the light of the day as
soon as possible because we need an
urgent decision and it is never too
early to address the problems of uh next
winter we are thankful to you for your
leadership and we are happy to work with
the European commission and with the
member states and we are at your
disposal thank you very much thank you
so much I will now take a few questions
there were many requests already please
note that there is a technical briefing
following this press conference so you
may save your more technical questions
for our experts from the European
commission and from the agency and let's
start from right Carl
um
good afternoon Mrs the president I have
three questions for you if I may
um I was very interested when you
mentioned the seven way the the
sovereignty fund sorry um can you please
give us more details on what it could
look like and what do you hear from the
member states about it do you sense an
appetite for it and do you think it is
time for the EU to have a new common
borrowing instrument and then I would
like to ask you about nuclear fusion we
hear from the United States that there
has been groundbreaking progress about
this technology is it something that the
EU is looking at and tonight you have a
very interesting dinner in in in Paris
what do you expect from your toes with
the Norwegians
yeah
um so the serenity fund
first of all again for the short term we
have repower EU which we have to boost
three power EU defines
the the investment
targets
and elements it's mainly the clean tech
sector it's Energy Efficiency it's uh
infrastructure that is needed and it's
Renewables and here we propose to boost
repower EU but we will certainly also
have to approach a midterm review of our
budget because our budget has been
decided at a time where we had no clue
of all the crisis coming up
um therefore the question is whether it
is still fit for purpose
and a fresh look through a midterm
review at the budget would open the door
to create a sovereignty fund that
certainly would not only be fed by
existing
European
funds that we have already in place but
would have then also to be augmented by
other sources but this is for the
midterm if we look at that the fusion
indeed we look at a lot of interest at
the Breakthrough that is being reported
on the nuclear fusion
this breakthrough is based on a
different technology pathway than ETA
so it demonstrates that the case to
continue investing in nuclear fusion is
strong and this of course includes
through ETA the the topic of etern
because eater is for example involving
also the United States as an integral
partner so we need various approaches to
securing this clean energy in the future
but it is very interesting and it shows
that it is worthwhile to intensify the
work and the research on Fusion
finally Norway
indeed our teams have been working
intensively
on this issue and I'm very much looking
forward to speak with the Norwegian
prime minister today
on one hand to take stock of the
progress and on the other hand also to
move forward you might recall that we
had a joint statement in October and
there we emphasized that we fully share
our on one hand the concerns about the
current level of high energy prices
that we agree politically and
economically they are unsustainable
and in that statement we together
expressed our determination that prices
should be significantly reduced what we
have to do is to work on a balance
between the short-term price reduction
and longer term Corporation
so we could for example look into the
option of uh longer term contracts but I
would also
um highly appreciate if there's a
possibility to have not region energy
supply companies joining our joint
purchase platform so to go also in that
topic and last but not least
um we uh both agree with the Norwegian
prime minister and me that was also part
of our statement that a massive
investment in clean energy production
has to be done with this amount of money
that is coming additionally to the
energy producing companies I want to
recall that Norway sent an additional
additional 9 billion cubic meter of gas
to Europe this year this is a lot
and it is important that these efforts I
know that they are really pushing their
efforts to the maximum that these
maximum efforts are being sustained
thank you very much
very much thank you Dan Irina with Greek
public TV and attention agency Madam
president the negotiations on price cup
are ongoing however the European
citizens are wondering why is it
impossible to reach an agreement faster
that could lower their bills and when
should we expect to have an agreement on
this correction mechanism thank you yeah
we all know that for the market
correction mechanism
um the issue is to find the right
balance
that we cut off the price spikes and
manipulation and speculation and on the
other hand that we do not cut off Supply
coming to the European market here we
have to find the right balance the
proposals on the table
a lot of work has been done the
technicalities are set
so what we need now is a political
agreement on what kind of price cap
where the balance is of what kind of
price cap we want so political agreement
on the scope on the threshold and the
threshold includes that we have that we
are aware that we have to include the
risk of demand reduction that we have to
include the security of supply and the
stability the financial stability those
three items have to be included in the
political decision on scope and
threshold I very much hope that we will
come to a conclusion within the next
days
thank you next one will be Alice
yeah well get another mic then
yeah it works
thank you sorry Alice financial times
thank you madam president for taking my
question
um I had two one is related to energy
um I wanted to ask um we're aware that
there's a huge effort to wean off
Russian hydrocarbons but there has also
been a huge jump in Imports of Russian
liquefied natural gas at the same time
what plants if any does the commission
have to reduce Reliance on uh Russian
LNG and an unengy related one uh
following the probe into Qatari
influence in the European Parliament we
saw of the weekend I wondered if you
could tell us whether the commission
will now pursue your proposal from 2019
to set up an Ethics body and if you
could update us on that pledge yeah
indeed
partially Russia tries partially to
circumvent
by increasing LNG supply to the European
market that's not easy to trace
but what we know is as overall the LNG
supply has increased the share of the
Russian LNG has decreased
so it is a mixed story and we have to
look deeper into it and look into
possibilities to make sure that we have
LNG from reliable suppliers but as I
said it's not easy to trace I I don't
know whether it's of interest for you to
comment on that too
look this is the the LNG imports from
Russia increase but from a very very low
levels the mean issue is the pipelines
and from the pipelines we are seeing a
major decline uh as I mentioned from 140
BCM to 60 BCM but the LNG input increase
it seems high in terms of percentage but
from in terms of the the absolute value
is about five six abcm which is really a
peanuts
yes and um to your second question
indeed the allegations against the vice
president of the European Parliament
are of utmost concern very serious
it is a question of confidence of people
into our institutions
and this confidence and Trust into our
institutions needs highest standards and
of Independence and integrity
and you're right I propose the creation
of an independent ethics body that
covers all EU institutions
and to be established with the highest
standards for all institutions it is
important I wrote this letter
um not only to council and the European
Parliament but for example also to the
European court of justice the ECB uh the
European Court of Auditors I'm speaking
about all institutions
I sent this letter in March
um the vice president eurova is
currently discussing with the European
Parliament that the council the way
forward
for us it is very critical
to have not only strong rules but the
same rules also covering all the
European institutions and not to allow
for any kind of exemptions so it's a
matter of transparency it's a matter of
very clear rules and all the European
institutions should abide to the same
rules that we put in place
I will not go on where we have a few
yes
could turn on your camera yes that's
great thank you thank you madam
president a quick question on joint
purchases the idea has been around for a
while but uh no big interest has been
seen from member states or companies
what are you planning to do in order to
encourage them to practically Implement
that and to Dr Barrel first of all does
the 30 BCM Supply demand Gap assume no
Russian gas and my second question would
be
how do you think the EU proposed gas
price cap could help or not help the
market thank you
so indeed with a joint purchase platform
we've established it and we have a
political agreement on it it's a
voluntary participation but what we've
seen over the last weeks is that the
interest is drastically increasing in
this joint platform because by now
almost everybody sees that it is
important that we join forces and have
this that's the leverage of our Joint
Forces on the global market so what we
need now is we have put a legal proposal
on the table and we hope and expect that
the council will agree on this legal
proposal within the next days
in terms of the 30 BCM 30 BCM assumes
first of all no Russian gas exports to
Europe and at the same time temperatures
go back to the normal season season
levels and the limited amount of uh LNG
so as a result we come to 30 BCM as I
mentioned if those measures in Europe
have not been taken this year this would
have been a 60 BCM but 30 BCM alone is a
major issue because
if you are not allowed if we are not
able to adjust this 30 BCM at the end of
the next winter season 90 of our
storages levels today will go to 30
percent uh only this is one in terms of
the gas price mechanism uh the gas price
cap mechanism I think this is a good
correction mechanism if it is well
designed to protect the consumers
because even though the gas prices are
today going coming down there are still
seven times higher than the the the
historical averages and here a
well-designed meaning it shouldn't give
a Europe uh the uh the role that it can
get gas from the other markets out
complete many others but at the same
time protect the consumers here the
level of the price will be here very
important but in general it's a good way
to go with the right price level
no
thank you Dana Madam president
um following up on the questions and
Qatar I have a few more of my own have
the Belgian authorities reached out to
the European commission regarding their
investigation and does their
investigation include any elements of
the activities of the European
commission members of the European
Parliament have noted several tweets and
public statements by vice president
Margarita skinas regarding Qatar you
yourself have been a supporter of Qatar
when it comes to LNG policy in the
European Union as part of your diplomacy
can you tell us if the European
commission stands behind Mr skinas and
all his public statements relating to
the World Cup are you conducting any
internal checks or investigations as to
all of your Commissioners visits to
Qatar and transactions with Kata
meetings with Qatar and so on and can
you say anything else about how the
European commission intends to deal with
this when it itself has taken a fairly
pro-cata stance given the scrutiny the
entire EU is under thank you
so as your as you know you work with
Qatar on global issues
such as climate change
we work with Qatar on Regional issues
such as peace and stability in
Afghanistan and the Middle East
and on bilateral issues such as the
diversification away from Russia Russian
fossil fuels
and of course the European Union remains
vocal on the issues where we see
problems for example through the regular
human rights dialogue that we have and
that takes place at a senior office
level official level so the last one was
in September
and the discussions we had on the
ongoing Qatari reform of its labor
market we have been working in close
coordination with the ILO so I think
this shows that there's a wide range of
different levels of work that has to be
done
um
I think it is important now to check
what the next topics are we are checking
on our site the transparency register
that we have we're all meetings of
college members and members of their
cabinets with interests representatives
are published so we are very transparent
on that one and that is the reason why
we think that we have
quite some experience how to establish
an Ethics body we have one with very
clear rules internally in the European
commission and again therefore I think
it is time to discuss whether we could
not establish this overall for All
European institutions I'm not advocating
that others join the same type we have
but the principles of having such an
Ethics body where there are very clear
rules on what has to be checked how and
when and what has to be published how
and when would be a big step forward
thank you very much now last question
Anita remotely
Madam president Anita British Phoenix
if I may uh with us again a written on
my instead I'd like to ask for a
statement in German on the scandal in
the European Parliament and the
consequences it will have
yeah
um
in that heart
indeed the allegations against the vice
president of the European Parliament are
very serious
and
we know that they are a cause for great
concern when it comes to the trust that
people place in our European
institutions we need the highest
standards and we need Independence and
integrity going Beyond those standards
and that is why
um some time ago I launched a process to
discuss with other European institutions
how we can achieve of reaching these
high standards of Independence and
integrity
from my point of view it would be
important to have an Ethics body we have
such an Ethics body here at the European
commission it doesn't have to be the
same one but what's important to me is
that we have clear rules and clear
standards across all European
institutions to ensure that we all have
the same control mechanisms and that we
um have and set these high standards for
Independence and integrity together vice
president Yoruba has already launched
discussions with the European Parliament
and the European Council the Council of
the EU and I hope this process can be
pushed forward the technical briefing on
energy which is starting a
I know that there were more colleagues
wanted to
several other press conferences
I'm sorry
[Music]
I'm sorry Oliver
I'm sorry Oliver
I'm sorry Oliver this is not the way to
organize a press conference here
I'm really sorry
I'm sorry Martina the president took
three questions which were outside the
scope of this press conference we have
another guest in the room and we are
going to conclude the press conference
here
so we are going to have another two
press conferences this week
[Music]
seriously so what the contact of the
Belgium authorities with the commission
is consent I would have to ask my staff
so this is a very clear question that we
would have to provide so I cannot answer
that one
and as I said we're checking every
detail on the transparency register we
have very clear rules for all
Commissioners we look into that with uh
in view of what has happened
um at the European Parliament and here
we have to check how the situation is
um I think as long as there are no new
informations
we are at the status quo but indeed if
any kind of new information occurs we
will have to act and react to that and
thank you very much for your patience
and understanding there will be two more
press conferences with the president
this week should new information arise
you will have the opportunity to hear
that thank you so much
foreign